[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es ein leckeres
roastbeef mit einer kräuter sesam
marinaden das roastbeef das habe ich
jetzt hier schon vorbereitet und zwar
habe ich warm abgewaschen und bereits
abgedruckt und es ist ganz wichtig dass
das roastbeef zimmer war mist ich zeige
euch mal die zutaten die ich dafür
benötigt für die marinade verwende ich
fünf esslöffel ach und sirup oder hellen
sirup drei esslöffel senf etwas öl salz
und pfeffer
ich habe ich das roastbeef das wiegt
etwa 1,2 kilo butter schmalz zum
anbraten und für die kräuterkruste habe
ich hier sesam petersilie rosmarin und
thymian
jetzt kann ich hier meine weißen fahne
schon mal erhitzen und ich brate fleisch
immer gerne in der eisenbahn an weil es
dann wirklich schön kross von außen wird
da kommt jetzt auch gleich butterschmalz
dazu denn fanden man nicht ohne inhalt
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon
mal die marinade zubereiten und
verrühren darf wird den ahorn sirup oder
ihr könnt auch den hellen sirup
verwenden
gemeinsam mit dem senf mit dem öl und
salz und pfeffer jetzt ist wichtig dass
das fleisch von allen seiten ganz
scharfen heiß angebraten wird und dann
kann es nämlich danach im ofen weiter
gang
[Musik]
das fleisch rundherum angebraten und die
pfanne wieder ausgemacht und habe jetzt
hier die marinade und kann sie jetzt
damit bestreichen und dann kommt
gemeinsam mit der marinade in den
backofen und darf da garen
und während der garzeit wenn ich es dann
immer mal wieder mit der marinade
bestreichen stelle ich es gemeinsam mit
der eisenbahn vornherein da musst du
natürlich sicherstellen dass eure pfanne
für den ofen geeignet ist ansonsten
einfach eine backform verwenden und ihr
könnt dann den ofen auf 120 grad ober
unterhitze stellen und dann seit 50 60
minuten garen
ich werde jetzt noch mit dem braten
thermometer kontrollieren und dann
einfach garzeit mache wunsch also wenn
ihr medium haben wollt ein bisschen
weniger garen und wenn er es lieber
durch haben wohl ein bisschen länger
[Musik]
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich auch
schon mal die kräuter ein bisschen
zupfen und fein hacken und damit dem
sesam vermischen
[Musik]
während das fleisch im ofen ist kann ich
schon mal den tomaten fit zu machen für
den tomaten verwendet gewürzgurken aus
dem glas eine chilischote cocktail
tomaten kapern tomatenmark salz und
pfeffer nämlich einfach die kurven die
tomaten und die werden alle fein
geschnitten
[Musik]
es gebe jetzt noch ein bisschen chili
rheinberg ein chili markt kann sich auch
weglassen oder ihr gebt chili
nachgeschmack dort so werden alle
zutaten vermischt mit den käufern da
hatte ich jetzt welche die wahren
eingelegt wenn sie war mit salz
eingelegt ein bisschen gucken wasser
tomatenmark
[Musik]
und jetzt könnt ihr das so einfach mal
abschmecken dann warte ich noch aufs
planschen und können wir beides
servieren nach der zeit habe ich das
fleisch aus dem ofen genommen und dann
einfach nur mal zehn minuten ruhen
lassen
jetzt ist es auch nicht mehr heiß und
ich kann es anfassen und einfach in
dieser kräuter panade schön wenn es hier
schön auf den teller legen nicht auf dem
bettchen und in scheiben schneiden und
servieren
[Musik]
dann noch ein bisschen tomaten dazu und
hier könnt ihr dann als beilage zum
beispiel total machen
das wird auch am besten passen denke ich
und dann habt ihr schon ein richtig
leckeres menü mit ganz wenig arbeit und
der moralisch gerade auch draußen nicht
höher in der baustelle da kommt bestimmt
gleich rein weil er das fleisch schon
recht aber ich probiere das jetzt mal
für euch
ich finde halt gerade diese kräuter
kanada außenrum richtig schön
der djp zu leicht
[Musik]
richtig lecker so ein roastbeef ist was
leckeres vor allem für den sonntag zum
beispiel da könnt ihr auch wirklich die
familie oder eure freunde beeindrucken
weil sie das rezept nach machen wollt
dann schaut auch sallys - blog.de vorbei
da steht sie noch mal ganz genau für
euch ich wünsche uns ja allen einen
guten appetit und euch natürlich auch
und viel spaß beim nachmachen
[Musik]